3 braucht der mensch smartphone
schlüssel bargeld oder sind es schlüssel
smartphone kreditkarte deutschland ist
gestalten immer mehr zahlen mit der
karte statt mit bargeld und durch die
korona krise boomt das karten zahlen
erst recht karte kontaktlos bekannte ich
eigentlich lieber jemand der mit echtem
geld zahlt weil ich das gefühl habe ich
hab dann ein besseres gefühl dafür wie
viel geld ausgebe aber jetzt durch pro
monat zahlen mit karte und man muss sich
auch fragen warum das bargeld
abgeschafft werden soll
manche banken setzen gar nicht mehr auf
bargeld sie haben weder filialen noch
geldautomaten bargeldlose bezahlen ist
am format experten aber warnen vor zu
großer datenüberwachung es ist ein kampf
der systeme bargeld gegen kartenzahlung
ein ehemaliger interpol chef warnt wenn
wir nur noch digital zahlen riskieren
wir viel was wäre wenn russland oder
jemand anders das bargeldlose system
einfach ausschaltet wir haben dann keine
verteidigung
zdfzoom corona pusch die karte wer
profitiert davon und welchen preis
zahlen wir dafür
ein leben ohne bargeld ein land von dem
bargeld gegner träumen
wie lebt es sich da in skandinavien ist
die zukunft längst angekommen
ich reise mit fairer und la auto fliegen
scheint mir hier in corona zeiten etwas
unsicher in dänemark finnland norwegen
und vor allem hier in schweden leben sie
fast war geld frei dann treffe ich will
einen deutschen der schon lange hier
lebt und an der uni arbeitet wann er das
letzte mal einen geldschein in der hand
hatte weiß ja gar nicht mehr genannt mit
dem karten und smartphone zahlen haben
schwedische banken und zahlungsanbieter
den bargeld ausstieg fast vollzogen
die meisten banken bieten gar kein
bargeld mehr an
zu umständlich gerade unter jungen
schweden boom smartphone zahlen geld von
handy zu handy schicken das geht so
leicht wie eine sms oder e-mail
versenden
geld ist hier nur noch eine digitale
information die schwedischen
zahlungsabwickler kriegen aber so nahezu
alles vom geldverkehr mit vater staat
bekommt fast alles mit und papa til
bekommt auch fast alles mit seinen
beiden kindern nämlich gibt hier das
taschengeld nicht bar
er überweist es selbstverständlich
online und hat dabei ziemlich guten
einblick was sohn miles alles so kauft
kann jede transaktion und das geschäft
wo er gekauft hat die zeit und wie viel
er bezahlt hat die kann ich sie und wie
siehst du wie viel da drauf ist ich weiß
es nicht aber weiß es aber er kann sehen
wie viel geld ich hab was ein bestimmtes
gefühl dass du noch geld übrig also ich
weiß dass ich etwas hilfe ich habe aber
ich wenn ich etwas für mehr als 20 grund
gab wieder empfehle ich nicht ein
bisschen sie gleichzeitig das nicht
machen das auch ganz gut als den meisten
zeit gesehen habe ich gesehen hast du
dich im juni es darunter unter 20
gehalten aber dafür regelmäßig ja dann
kann man wächst wenn man das so sehen
kann
wir hatten sie sind wirklich jeder
einkauf ist aufgelistet
anstelle dass man jetzt auch tilt
tochter lou zahlt nur noch mit karte und
gelegentlich mit smartphone wie ist dass
sein vater kann auch sehen was zu
überweisen oder was so ein kauf genau
oder ich glaube er kann sehen war wo ich
einkaufe nicht was ich hoffe auf der
bank hatte aber das beeindruckt ich
nicht jetzt
mit meinem bargeld wird mir klar bin ich
hier ziemlich aufgeschmissen
meine eigens abgehobenen kronen werde
ich so leicht gar nicht los eher
zufällig bei einem kleinen provinz
imbiss ein thailänder ist so freundlich
mich in schweden bar zahlen zu lassen
erst schweden die zukunft eine zukunft
in der wir nahezu kein bargeld mehr
haben dafür genauen einblick wer wann wo
wie für was zahlt wien die größte
wirtschafts universität europas wie wir
alle permanent beim digitalen bezahlen
beobachtet und analysiert werden
erforscht sarah spiekermann ihr seit
vielen jahren
sie meint mit kreditkarteninformationen
und digitalen bezahldaten habe sich eine
riesige kaum kontrollierbare industrie
von datenhändlern entwickelt
mittlerweile haben wir eine echtzeit
beobachtung aller menschen über alle
digitalen medien die sie in irgendeiner
form nutzen um profile von
grössenordnungen zu erstellen wo zu mama
30 40.000 daten pro person fast der
normalfall sind und über diese hoch
aufgelöste historie an dem was man tut
wo man lang fährt was man kauft was man
bezahlt wo man in urlaub fährt wie viel
man wie viel man bezahlt all diese
informationen wie viel alkohol man filme
wie viel alkohol man drin noch auf
solche sachen können rausgerechnet
werden und können dann dem
höchstbietenden verkauft werden der
effekt daten über unser
zahlungsverhalten bestimmen zunehmend
unseren alltag ohne dass wir verstehen
oder einsehen könnten wie es dazu komme
könnten wir die folgen erleben nicht nur
beim einkaufen
was das eigentlich ganz normale ähnliche
leute unterschiedliche preise
beispielsweise für flugtickets für
hotels für alles mögliche bezahlen
müssen plötzlich oder dass ich nicht
versichert werden oder dass ich kein
jobangebot bekommen dieses systematische
unglück was mir plötzlich begleitet und
ich denke das wäre mein schicksal in
wirklichkeit sind es irgendwelche
datenbanken die irgendwas über mich
ausrechnen wo im hintergrund leute daran
geld verdienen dass sie diese profile
von mir stellen das heißt das ist
würdelos je bequemer je kontaktlose und
vielleicht auch hygienischer unser
bezahlprozess wird desto mehr
informationen fließen also auf die
andere seite was firmen dort über mich
wissen werde ich wohl nie erfahren
dass es auch anders geht modernes
bezahlen nur ohne die ganzen datenspuren
das zeigt das berliner unternehmen bar
zahlen punkt.de klingt nach geldscheinen
und münzen
aber so ganz analog ist es dann doch
nicht eher eine mischform aus internet
und cash nicht an der bar zahler sind
digital muffel natürlich gibt es auch
eine große gruppe die baguette
insbesondere auch im digitalen umfeld
nutzen möchte weil sie eben ihre
persönlichen daten nicht so gerne online
preisgeben weil es bargeld hat viele
möglichkeiten und vorteile es ist anonym
ich kann das nutzen ich brauche
keinerlei vorkehrungen dafür ich muss
keine karte besitzt muss irgendwo kunde
sein
also wenn ich mir eine welt überlege wo
es kein bargeld mehr gibt bin ich als
europa als deutschland abhängig von zwei
großen amerikanischen kreditkartenfirmen
die unseren gesamten zahlungsverkehr
kontrollieren möchte ich das bezahlen
das geht dann zum beispiel im
einzelhandel und zwar so egal ob ich für
einen online einkauf im internet
bezahlen will
ob ich vom amt einen betrag bekomme oder
zahlen muss oder ob ich geld von meinem
konto ein oder aus zahlen möchte immer
bekomme ich einen verschlüsselten
barcode geschickt mit dem ich an der
kasse zahle oder einzahler der barcode
gibt an wie viel geld ein oder
ausgezahlt wird
es werden keinerlei konto oder
kreditkartendaten von mir übertragen und
für die nächste zahlung gibt es einfach
einen neuen barcode dieser barcode wird
ganz einfach an der kasse gescannt und
daraufhin seit die kassiererin eben 50
euro bargeld aus in diesem fall ist das
eine abhebung von bankkonto das könnte
jetzt aber auch eine rückerstattung sein
für ein paar schuhe was ich im online
handel gekauft habe es könnte eine
rückzahlung sein für eine zuviel
bezahlte stromrechnung es könnte auch
eine bezahlung sein dh das knöllchen von
karten
der barcode ist immer der gleiche ist es
auch nicht ersichtlich was
tatsächlich jetzt hier gemacht habe also
die informationen werden nicht an einen
dritten weiter gegeben das bargeld
retten irgendwie damit nicht alle alles
wissen karte oder cash corona spitzt
auch diesen konflikt zu digitales zahlen
ist durchaus bequem schnell und fühlt
sich sicher an banken und zahl systemen
bringt das riesige gewinne im gegenzug
macht die daten branche gigantische
umsätze und durchdringt unser leben
tiefer als wir ahnen